ولكن هنا حيث تصبح الأشياء رائعة حقًا
يمكنني الكشف عنها ورؤية
الخريطة على الفور على الشاشة الكبيرة وهذا أمر مذهل ، لذلك
لنفترض أن جوش يريد مشاهدة
YouTube والدردشة مع صديقه على تطبيق whatsapp
في نفس الوقت على اليسار
يتم تشغيل فيديو YouTube على  على اليمين ، يقوم
بمراسلة صديق وإذا كان يحتاج إلى
تصفح الويب ، فهو موجود في
النافذة الثالثة مباشرةً ، وإذا أراد التصفح
في النافذة الأكبر ، فيمكنه فعل ذلك أيضًا ،
فكل ما عليك فعله هو سحب
المتصفح إلى النافذة الأكبر
الشاشة والكاميرا مرنة تمامًا مثل
باقي الأجهزة في الواقع ، إنها في الواقع
عبارة عن نظام مكون من ست كاميرات ، ثلاث كاميرات في
الخلف ، اثنتان في الخلف وواحدة في
الأمام مع Galaxy Fold ، يمكنك الحصول على
هاتف ذكي قوي وجهاز لوحي ثوري.
في حزمة واحدة متميزة
، تأتي الطية في كل من إصدار LTE و 5 G
بدءًا من
1900 دولارًا حسب
منطقتك وشركة الاتصالات ، ويمكنك الحصول على
galaxy fold الخاص بك بدءًا من 26 أبريل